[Musique]
alors on ouvre les micros on garde la
musique en sourdine vous êtes bien à la
bonne adresse de tam-tam canada en
direct de montréal 11 ans 11 le vendredi
c'est là on magique
après les bulletins d'information vous
vous allez mettre votre télévision de
côté vous venez à l'ordinateur nous
regarder ici à travers le monde entier
on regarde la caméra 22 cette semaine
[Musique]
fantastique on a avec nous pas l'eau
martinez bonjour et puis ça mur bénéteau
avec moussa saïb ans j'allais dire c'est
pas noël pourquoi est-ce qu'on a ce
cadeau en studio mais quand c'est un
véritable répertoire est passé plutôt
mais oui pour passer avant noël ou s'ils
lui ça et puis nous on joue mal et les
webmestres ici ou services français de
radio canada le service non l'équipe
française à l'équipe espagnole qui nous
est prêté comme ça pour ces services
sont alain il ya notre autre webmestre
de la section d'actions américaines nom
de l'équipe peut latino américains léo
gimeno bonjour des eaux bonjour bonjour
bonjour alors vous connaissez le jeu wii
l'émission est un jeu ça n'est pas une
farce mais c'est un jeu d'accord trois
jeux durant l'émission
vous partez avec 100 points et offert
mesures que les jeux déboule avec la
grosse boule vous perdez des points
voilà mais avant d'aller aux jeux vous
maintenez vos prouesses de se faire le
jeu pour le moment le jeu 7 soit vous
étiez prêts à décoller sept prêts pour
décollage oui vidéo cette image vous
devinez quel est le sujet cette semaine
de l'émission dès que vous sentez que
sur une piste manifestez vous sinon
votre collègue va vous enlevez commerce
entre les pays
continuez c'est très bon vous êtes sur
la bonne piste on vous cache nouveaux
accords oui c'est ça pourrait que ça va
peut-être faire partie de la question
bien sûr mais ça c'est la chine monsieur
jean du pin thouet lycées qui s'est levé
[Musique]
le poing
même si on va parler de l'homme sait ce
qu on va parler de la réponse en bière
si la réponse est aussi spécifiquement
l'initiative canadienne pour réformer
l'om sait puisque nous on va expliquer
on va expliquer la petite partie de
casse tête que le canada possède un
petit morceau comme ça qui pourrait
faire la différence avec quelqu'un qui
je pense est partie des négociations
qu'on va avoir des annonces à faire
aujourd'hui mais pour nous mettre dans
le bain pour mieux comprendre ce que
c'est l'om c'est tout ça le même c'est
qu'ils l'organisation mondiale du
commerce de faire un rapide test en
général ici en anglais comment on
appelle l omc
wt au tableau c'est très bon en espagnol
le paloma comment on appelle ça et puis
j'étais originaire de l'argentine et on
parle en argentine l'espagnol
oui non le portugais vous le dis ah oui
je te faisais ça des erreurs quand
j'étais jeune alors écoutez comment
descendre vraiment les gens qui
s'occupent pas ce que faisons nous de
nos affaires
elle intervient un petit peu à dans les
sociétés koffi koffi commerciaux fermés
tandis qu'elle a peut-être qu'elles
jouent le jeu d'autres super puce 1
c'est que les règles du jeu sont un jeu
où la chine vérité on va vérifier ça
aujourd'hui
pour le moment c'est le premier jeu la
grosse boule combien de points à perdre
pour ce premier jeu sur son prêt c'est
le règlement
il ya deux semaines tout gagner des
points vous en perdez
vous savez que je l'inventé sans même
m'en rendre compte
c'est ça c'est ça le génie c'est comme
newton mais il est tombé la pop
c'est pas la première fois où vous
faites preuve de génie alors que ça ne
soit pas vous sabotez comme sur pen
alors l'om c'est né le 1er janvier 1995
ce jour je vous donne cette information
je vous ai un petit peu mais le système
commercial qu'elle représente a presque
plus que puisque c'est en 1947 a
commencé les accords du gatt ensuite
d'autres accords généraux je passe les
détails savoir nuit les étudiants car
finalement je vous demande combien il ya
des tas qui sont membres aujourd'hui de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce
convient pas de choix de départ celui
qui est plus proche du but à 9 89 très
bien combien de pays dans le monde
192 194 vous n'êtes pas loin s'en
convainc 14 mai le canada reconnaît un
plus que les autres 195,2 kosovo alors
pour les canadiens à sa connerie 15 pour
les autres on atteindra 14 d'accord ça 5
kg 120 120 pays font partie
sur 104 68 60 et alors mais 89 89 68
samedi 120 80 80 alors vous perdez tous
devaient point ici ici ici vous
conservez vos 20 points j'ai dit combien
c'est 170
attendez je pense et 164 165 parce qu'il
y à 5 94 ou 95 oui j'ai un billet de mon
pays d'origine parce qu'il n'est pas
membre donc tout le monde
moi je dis 164 soit 165 on va demander à
notre spécialiste
un qu'ils connaissent à david pavot
chargé de cours à la faculté de droit de
l'université de sherbrooke et c'est
vraiment un expert en la matière de l'om
c'est du droit international monétaire
et financier les accords de libre
échange
on l'appelle à l'instant le voici qui
apparaît sur au fait ça on avait un
petit débat ici on savait pas combien
d'états étaient membres de l'om c'est
160 465 y avait un gros débat est ce que
vous auriez le chiffre exact 164 depuis
la 2ème conférence ministérielle
donnez-moi le rpt et à des deux membres
et le yémen au très bien quelle année ça
2015 et la chine c'est en quelle année
qu'elle est devenue membre de mc il y
avait un gros débat à l'époque oui votre
image à geler un petit peut donc
continuer à parler ça va ça va se passer
tout va bien tout va bien ça va on vous
voit et on vous entend surtout san
important ouais ouais c'est bon donc
vous me disiez la chine pardon oui h et
dans quelle année la chine et non en
2001 en 2001 et tant d'années plus tard
voilà que donald trump s'offusque j'ai
l'impression qu'il se fût ce qu'à fait
mouche spécialisés ces affaires là mais
il semble qu'ils contestent même la
présence de la chine dans le mc ou ou la
façon dont la chine se comporte alors
qu'elle est membre de l'ump
quelle est la bonne version ils comptent
ils contestent pas la présence de la
chine à l'om c'est éthique ont ils à une
contestation générale de ce qu'elle
organisait
sion et il a une compte et surtout sur
les bienfaits ou les méfaits que le
commerce international peut causer sur
l'économie américaine on connaît la
rengaine on l'a déjà entendu sur la lena
l'ob umc et il conteste aussi le statut
qui est octroyé à la chine et qui a un
statut particulier que on a reconnu à la
chine en 2001 quand la chine est devenue
membre de l' omc et ce statut et une
statut dérogatoire qui est donné à la
chine qui permet au gouvernement chinois
de maintenir des subventions notamment à
certaines industries
alors c'est une petite technique qualité
et nous en échange en tant que pays
développés eh bien on surtaxe déjà de
manière en prenant en compte celle ce
régime particulier les produits qui sont
importés de la chine
donc c'est une technicalité kiki qui
offre à la chine un statut particulier
et finalement c'est nous qui avons exigé
de la chine en 2001 qui avons dire la
chine il faut vous soyez ranger dans
cette boîte là et aujourd'hui on semble
vouloir du moins le gouvernement de
l'administration de crème sans vouloir
en sortir pour des motifs qui sont ces
c'est un petit peu difficile à
comprendre
même d'un point de vue juridique
pourrait même pour nous qui sommes
négociateurs à l'om sont un petit peu de
mal à le congrès vous êtes un
spécialiste du droit international
même je pense que je devais je me trompe
mais faites vous partie des négociations
au niveau d'une révision du modèle de
l'om c'est tel que le propose le canada
est ce que c'est alors alors est-ce que
je négocie en tant que tel
est-ce que je suis associé à la réforme
de wall sinon je suis négociateur
allemand pour le gouvernement mais je
suis les questions relatives à la
gouvernement le bénin le bénin club donc
je suis conseiller du ministre du bénin
pendant les négociations est ce que ça
se fait en multilatérale ou bilatérale
juste comme ça un petit détail je
voulais comprendre alors les
négociations commerciales se font de
manière multilatérale c'est à dire qu'on
négocie alors les états négocié tous à
genève au sein du conseil de manière
constante et il négocie aux deux ans
lors de grands
deux réunions au cours desquelles les
ministres du commerce des différents
états sont réunis c'est ce qu'on appelle
les conférences ministérielles la
dernière s'est tenue à buenos aires et
son rapport aujourd'hui parce que selon
lors du salon qui engage l'organisation
est la dernière s'est produit deux
cousines on vous en a perdu que vous
avez la dernière en cas la crise en un
dessin merci en 2000 alors on essaie de
vivre à travers ce jeu se comment on
appelle ça un jeu abstrait ça au moins
on communique bien si on examine comment
ça peut se passer au niveau de certains
pays les disputes l'om s'est pas
toujours clair c'est pas toujours
propres dans le monde de donald trump et
dans le monde de donald trump est ce que
l'om c'est existerait où ce serait une
autre une autre affaire je sais de
comprendre parce que les américains
c'est quand même encore la plus première
puissance économique mondiale
quand même je pense oui alors dans le
monde de donald trump qu'on aurait un
monde qui serait bien différent il faut
faire il nous vous permettons à te faire
un petit retour depuis 1945 les états
unis sont le leader de ce qu'on appelle
nous le multilatéralisme commerciale
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que ce sont eux qui veulent que l'on
promeuvent l'échelon international
un système basé sur le libre échange
desquels ils sont le moteur depuis 1945
le nouveau président trump on le sait il
a une vision bien différente du commerce
international ou pour lui le commerce
international c'est pas des gains
collectif
finalement il a une vision de deux
vendeurs de ou de courtiers immobiliers
à peu près en quelque sorte ou pour lui
le commerce international se comprend un
gain bilatéraux c'est à dire il veut
bien ouvrir ses frontières à la
condition que les etats-unis soient
gagnants or aujourd'hui on le sait le
commerce international c'est plus du
tout ça on s'inscrit dans ce qu'on
appelle des chaînes de valeur mondiales
donc c'est à dire où les marchandises
sont fabriqués à travers des dizaines et
des dizaines de pays et finalement ben
quand on fabrique une ode aux 60
quand enfin davis qui viennent du
mexique ça va être assemblés pour partie
aux états unis ou au canada
donc finalement la logique commerciale
de donald trump qui est bilatérale c'est
une logique du commerce qu'on voyait au
xviiie siècle en quelque sorte qui est
plus du tout la vision contemporaine et
qui n'est plus du tout une vision
réaliste du commerce international
d'ailleurs quand on parle avec des
manufacturiers américains il fonde et
ils font des bonds sur leur chaise à
chaque fois que le président trump prend
la parole en matière commerciale
mais je l écoute des citoyens du monde
on entend souvent dire l'om s'est elle
va trop loin et l'om c'est nous impose
ce si l'om s'est elle prend des
décisions qui sont difficiles à accepter
il ya beaucoup de protestation même au
canada par rapport à certaines des
décisions qui ont été prises dans le
passé on a l'impression qu'on se fait
imposer quelque chose par une entité
extérieure et je sais qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens qui parlent de l'existence
éventuelle d'un gouvernement mondial et
cetera mais j'essaye à l'autre court à
penser également qui sera porsche
d'ailleurs de celui de monsieur trompe
et je pense qu'il ya un fond vérité
quelque part par rapport à une présence
mal expliqué mal coordonnés peut-être il
ya plusieurs il ya plusieurs degrés
d'expliquer ya plusieurs choses a
expliqué sur votre question la première
chose libéralisation à coup ça c'est
certain et un coût humain important
quand on libéralise un secteur
malheureusement ça se calcule à
l'échelle d'une génération donc
finalement si on libéralise le secteur
du textile mais il ya des gens qui vont
père qui ont perdu - sherbrooke je le
connais très bien je travaillais bien
c'est de charbon comme vous le savez bas
à un de mes anciens condos c'était une
ancienne usine de textile pourquoi parce
que finalement on a perdu 7,7
compétences parce que on n'est pas
compétitif dans le secteur du textile on
a une main d'oeuvre qui coûte plus cher
et trop cher et malheureusement les gens
qui perdent leur travail souvent dans
des industries finalement à faible
revenu quand on parle l'industrie
manufacturière et bien ces gens là ils
ont des difficultés pour retrouver un
travail derrière on pas formé où ils
n'ont pas les diplômes nécessaires
donc c'est certain que là il ya un
travail à faire au niveau des
gouvernements et qui est pas toujours
bien fait l'autre chose ensuite c'est
que effectivement il ya un déficit de
connaissance de ce que fait
l'organisation et de ce qu'elle organise
a sion et de ce qu'est le commerce
international pourquoi alors il ya deux
niveaux
parce que c'est facile quand on est un
homme politique de dire ce n'est pas de
ma faute c'est la faute de quelqu'un
d'autre et de taper sur le dos d'une
organisation qui dont personne de
finalement dont sauf les initiés
connaissent les tenants et les
aboutissants on l'entend encore à québec
aujourd'hui lorsqu'on nous dit que le
gouvernement de la province va s'opposer
à la ratification de la umc je suis un
peu désolé de dégonfler la balloune de
françois legault et des partis
d'opposition ils peuvent pas faire grand
chose mais c'est facile pour eux de dire
c'est de la faute de l'accord et c'est
de la faute du fédéral si il y peuvent
rien l'autre enfin un dernier degré de
réponse c'est que oui ça cool commerce
international mais aussi on en profite
énormément de dire aujourd'hui est-ce
qu'on serait prêts à réindustrialiser le
canada par exemple et à fabriquer des
lave linge au canada si on discute avec
monsieur madame tout le monde dans la
rue les gens vont dire oui c'est une
bonne idée moi aussi en tant que citoyen
je trouve que c'est une bonne idée sauf
qu'après il ya un principe de réalité
qui s'opposaient ce qu'on ait fait après
à payer trois ou quatre fois le prix de
notre lave linge sans que nos salaires
augmentent c'est ça aussi qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que aujourd'hui il faut
faire un examen de conscience
individuelle et regarder si si on
regarde si j'ai regardé la chemise que
j'ai je regarde les tic est allé made in
vietnam si je regarde ma veste elle est
certainement made in portugal et si je
regarde ma cravate elle doit être made
in china
mais si je veux du made in canada ma
chemise qui étaient fabriqués au vietnam
est le coût de 25 $
si je me suis je là même que vous
cheminez fabriqués au canada elle va
coûter 75 ou 100 dollars
est ce que je suis prêt à avoir juste de
chemise dans mon gars de rob howley d'en
avoir dit ça c'est un examen de
conscience qu'on doit faire tout un
chacun et ça c'est aussi des bénéfices
du commerce international que l'on a
d'abord de pouvoir s'équiper moins cher
de pouvoir avoir des produits qui
coûtent moins cher mais ça c'est les
conséquences des règles du commerce
international et on en est pas toujours
conscients mais oui il ya des pertes
d'emplois et oui ça peut être aussi des
conséquences négatives des conséquences
qui sont difficiles à accepter pour les
citoyens paloma a fait vous parliez des
dents de bénéfices et des cet examen de
conscience concernant ce bénéfice du
commerce international mais quelles sont
donc les conséquences négatives du
commerce international du point de vue
de l'om sait pas ce que vous faites vous
même un examen des comptes des
consciences alors les conséquences
négatives du commerce international par
certains égards c'est il ya une sorte de
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que on dit
souvent que c'est un gouvernement
mondial comme vous l'avez dit qu il faut
que c'est les états qui acceptent ces
règles qu'ils aient négocié qu'il ait
conclu
donc finalement les règles qui nous sont
à qui nous sont imposées c'est les
règles qu'on a librement consenti donc
ya pas nécessairement de gouvernement
mondial ou de complot mondial au delà de
ça c'est surtout des règles auxquelles
on s'appuie getti donc en fait les les
difficultés les difficultés surtout moi
je les vois comme une absence de
capacité de la part des gouvernements
qu'ils soient des gouvernements des pays
développés ou dpi développement a bien
joué dans ses règles à bien manipuler
ces règles je m'explique en critique
souvent on dit souvent que quand on
signe des accords de libre-échange bien
on va avoir des produits qui sont pas
fabriqués dans les mêmes conditions
humaines de droit de respect des droits
humains ou de respect des normes
sanitaires
c'est vrai c'est vrai que c'est pas tout
à fait les mêmes normes mais dans les
accords on a tout à fait des règles qui
permettent au gouvernement de s'opposer
à l'importation de tels produits les
étals sont pas toujours
alors pourquoi parce qu'il ya des
raisons de politique derrière il ya des
raisons de relations internationales que
s'il ya des questions de connaissances
de la part des fonctionnaires qui n'ont
pas toujours là et encore au canada on
est plutôt bien loti donc oui il ya des
effets positifs il ya des effets
négatifs il ya plusieurs effets négatifs
qu'on pourrait contrer finalement si on
si on soutire si on soutient un petit
peu mieux et si on agissait si on met
les gouvernements utilisé un petit peu
mieux les règles
maintenant c'est aussi une tâche
d'éducation qu'on va faire vis-à-vis de
nos gouvernants on essaie de la faire
vous voyez on n'était pas plus tard que
j'étais pas plus tard qu'au vietnam la
semaine par ici et on leur expliquer
certaines règles en matière de droits
humains dans les accords qu'on a avec
eux en leur disant vous avez des pas à
faire au niveau de droite pour que vos
produits fait librement apporté au
canada samir avant poser une question
j'aurais comprendre pourquoi pas le mans
n'a pas l'air d'accord avec la réponse
est d'accord je trouve que c'est
complexe parce que un fait juste la
notion même du pay du pays des pays en
développement et des pays développés et
déjà n'est pas égalitaire
parce que oui le vietnam doit faire des
efforts au niveau des droits humains
de niveau des trois semaines concernant
les travailleurs dans les usines etc
mais si le dessin instances
internationales de termine un peu les
prix comme qu'on est prêt à payer pour
un produit c'est difficile pour les
états aussi et pour la population de se
révéler contre ceux contre ça donc je me
demande jusqu'à quel point c'est
possible de trouver un équilibre dans
cette disparité des pays dans le monde
je suis peut rajouter juste à ça à ce
que les états ne négocie à égalité quand
on est si dense qu'il négociait à
égalité alors parler alors il ya
plusieurs questions
je vais commencer par là par la dernière
de revenir aux autres hes qui négociait
à égalité en principe oui parce qu'à
l'om c'est le mode de décision c'est le
consensus c'est à dire que vous soyez
les îles kiribati où les états unis vous
avez même le même pouvoir pour adopter
une règle pour la refuser
donc ça c'est une première chose donc à
priori oui après d'un point de vue de la
règle du nombre et de la règle de la
compétence
c'est là qu'ils aient une inégalité vous
dire quand on s'appelle les états unis
le canada ou encore l'union européenne
on n'a pas les mêmes moyens pour emmener
des experts avec nous que lorsqu'on a
lorsqu'on s'appelle le bénin par exemple
moi je craque comme je voulais dit je
travaille pour le gouvernement du bénin
lors des grandes conférences
ministérielles il à la délégation du
meilleur des six il ya le ministre
l'ambassadeur à genève un conseiller la
secrétaire du ministre et des experts
étrangers qui viennent à tout bénévole
est-ce que ça les intéresse alors que si
vous comparez avec la délégation des
états unis c'est 70 personnes qui sont
compare avec la délégation de l'union
européenne
ces 300 personnes mais dans les salles
de négociations on n'est pas plus que
deux ou trois toujours par état donc
c'est à dire que j'ai pas 300 européen
enfin je voulais j'espère qu'il est
toujours un oui on a fallu père
d'accueil
ok donc pour cesse d'augmenter mais
toujours bon deuxième question je
reviens à la première question qui était
posée
oui il ya une inégalité dans les normes
mais faut pas encore une fois oublié
c'est que ces normes les états laisse
comme je voulais vie préalable on les
adopte volontairement et on ne force
personne à les adopter
alors est ce que la société civile a
quelque chose à faire évidemment évident
non et à mon sens problème majeur c'est
un des êtres un désintérêt de la société
civile pour ces questions commerciales
je vous en parlais en deux mots ça fait
six ans que je suis négociateurs à l'om
c'est au début je voulais y aller pour
une ong et je me suis adressé à un angle
des ong canadiennes et pouvant
faramineuses et équiterre la fondation
david suzuki- bref je les ai tout fait
en leur disant il ya des mois ça
m'intéresse d'y aller d'y aller pour la
société si nietzsche créateur du
lobbying pour vous si vous me confier un
mandat
leur réponse a été il ya plus rien à
gagner tout est perdu or il ya des
choses réelles pour la société civile
est aujourd'hui qui est ce qui va pour
la société civile au canada par exemple
eh bien c'est l'union des producteurs
agricoles
c'est là je peux vous dire que eux ils
si ils sont en masse et ils font bien
leur job et les la société civile est
l'archi au sens large finalement les ong
qui font du militantisme pour les droits
humains ou pour le droit de
l'environnement par exemple ne sont
malheureusement plus là et aujourd'hui
dans la société si alors que la société
civile par exemple est très très
présente aux négociations climatiques et
c'est un gros poids qu'on peut mettre
sur les gouvernements parce que quand on
se retrouve à 25 ong de produire 25
représentants des producteurs agricoles
du québec
bah c'est pas le même poids que quand
vous avez juste une personne et demi qui
est là pour parler par exemple de la
condition des femmes dans le commerce
international ou du respect des droits
humains
alors que si on avait de 200
représentants ben le poids il serait pas
le même non plus la société part des
inégalités et puis des questions de
poids on va passer à graffer cas là la
caméra vous ne le verrez pas mais vous
connaissez le contenu j'en suis sûr
c'est un graphique qui montre
l'importance des différentes économies
appartenant à les 20 premières
industries ou pays au monde appartenant
à l'om c est leur poids relatif par
rapport aux autres et on si on regarde
la vidéo à voir évidemment qu'est la
chine qui est la première au niveau des
exportations par des exportations
il devient en deuxième suivi de
l'allemagne et le canada
on le retrouve il ya un petit astérix il
va apparaître sur notre graphique des
que youtube va permettre la diffusion de
ce graphique parce que là il est youtube
est un peu collet c'est pas comme
l'accélérateur et ses collègues ça
décolle pas mais voilà on est rendue je
pense en 10e position au niveau des
déportations
on est des grands exportateurs de
nourriture dans le monde
je pense qu'on est à peine 1 % de la
population mondiale ont nourri 3% de la
population
évidemment on a nos ressources premières
qui qui permettent de faire rouler les
autos dans le monde
l'aluminium soit c'est nous dassier même
aux états unis est encore présent nous
permettent pétrole oui écoutez le canada
est tout petit comment comment le style
une initiative pour réformer l'om c'est
face aux géants qui commande qui ont qui
ont tous le poids des grandes décisions
ça c'est pas de questions non depuis le
début on vous pose et d'excellentes
questions comment est ce que le canada
peut faire le canada s'est toujours été
vu comme une puissance finalement
médiane moyenne très impliqué sauf la
parenthèse du gouvernement harper pour
le multi rail multi multilatéral serre
de manière générale que ce soit en
matière de droits de l'homme en matière
de commerce etc
à l'om sait on à un blocage actuellement
le blocage
on a un blocage depuis d'ailleurs buenos
aires est sur le programme de
négociations c'est ça le gros problème
c'est on ne s'entend plus sur ce qu'on
doit négocier depuis 2001 négocié dans
le cadre du programme de doha sur le
développement donc l'idée c'était de
compenser un petit peu les inégalités
qu'il y avait sur le développement on a
fait des gros progrès en 2013 à bali et
en 2015 à nairobi
et depuis finalement depuis depuis
décembre dernier la machine c'est un
petit peu enrayée depuis décembre 2010
est et on s'entend pas sur programme de
négociation donc ça c'est vraiment ce
que cherche à faire le canada c'est
établir un programme de négociations qui
soit inclusif et qui conviennent au plus
grand nombre
alors on n'a pas invité les états unis
et on n'a pas invité la chine
alors est ce que c'est c'est
certainement volontaire parce qu'on sait
qu'il ya un antagonisme avec entre la
chine et les états unis mais c'est aussi
l'idée d'amener un nombre de 1 nombre
structurel de pays suffisant qui partage
un point de vue commun pour finalement
dire la voilà on est un groupe d'une
trentaine quarantaine d'états pays
développés et pays en développement qui
s'entendent pour arriver à une nouvelle
proposition sur le programme la
négociation donc ça c'est une première
chose c'est
le gros morceau de la réforme de la
seconde réforme qui est quelque chose
d'un peu plus de technique c'est le
mécanisme de règlement des différends de
l'om sait on sait qu'au sein de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce il
ya un juge qui est chargée de trancher
les litiges entre les états c'est un
mécanisme qui fonctionne très
fonctionnel très bien avec un mécanisme
d'appels depuis la création de
l'organisation en 1995 il ya plus de 500
litiges ont été tranchées entre les
zetas et c'est incomparable
au niveau international on n'a aucune
cour qui tranche autant de litige
actuellement il ya déjà plusieurs
litiges pendants sur les surtaxes sur
l'aluminium et l'acier finalement toute
la guerre commerciale entre les états
unis et essai et certains états et
depuis l'administration obama les états
unis pour tout un tas de raisons bloque
la nomination des juges
pourquoi alors jours pour faire une
histoire courte c'est parce qu'il
reproche au juge
le fait d'intégrer trop de valeur non
commerciales dans leur juste avant tes
gré des questions de respect de
l'environnement et de respect des droits
humains et finalement de dépasser leurs
cadres stricto sensu donc c'est pas tant
une antagonismes et vis-à-vis du
mécanisme judiciaire que les avis de la
manière dont les juges travaillent donc
est-ce qu'on va est ce que c'est si
grave que ça non c'est pas si grave que
le mécanisme ne soient réformés ou pas
parce que la question porte uniquement
sur l'organe d'appel et on a toujours à
un juge de première instance qu'on
appelle les groupes spéciaux donc
finalement oui ça peut se bloquer mais
finalement il y aura toujours un juge de
première instance qui on pourra pas
faire appel donc moi ce que ce que je
vis un petit peu aux états avec lesquels
je travaille c'est continuer continuer à
poursuivre qui appartient donc un
continue à tourner finalement qu'en fait
ce niveau voire qu'ils sont cons là
nominale pourtant on n'est pas aux états
alors vous aviez un appel peut être
guéri non non c'est la connexion qui
était bizarre donc je disais je sais
plus je sais pas quel niveau ce à quoi
bon continuer à travailler peut-être
éventuellement les états unis vont finir
par changer de président c'est sur cette
crise dans un ca arrive pas
nécessairement donc
la politique commerciale station ckoi
que mr obama s'était pas à peu près la
même chose ça d'écouté oui au niveau des
juges mais de manière générale tous les
présidents américains depuis depuis une
trentaine d'années lorsqu'il était en
campagne alors ce qu'ils avaient à la
maison blanche
vous voulez adopter des positions contre
le libre-échange et ils se sont tous
fait rattraper très rapidement par leurs
conseillers en leur disant attention ce
à un coût pour les états unis est
finalement le seul qui écoutent pas
vraiment c'est le président entre eux
donc finalement il ya eu finalement la
position l'antagonisme est dixième du
commerce international est plus élevé
avec rome qu'il était avec obama une
dernière question oui donc si les états
unis sont un peu à qui vont à l'encontre
du reste du monde concernant l'om c'est
qu'est ce qui arriverait si jamais les
pays décident de s'extraire de cette
instance lahoud vraiment faire
complètement fidesz a pu faire autre
chose que ça paraisse si les états unis
décident de sortir de pau mcc eux qui
vont en payer le prix est très très cher
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que le fait
d'être membre de l'organisation mondiale
du commerce permet d'avoir une relation
commerciale et commerciales stables avec
tous ses partenaires donc c'est à dire
qu'on ne peut pas relever
sauf à se mettre en violation les droits
de douane de manière exponentielle
donc si les états unis sortent
finalement on va pouvoir faire n'importe
quoi à leur égard et finalement que
c'est eux qui vont en payer le prix donc
c'est une police et une position qui
serait largement finalement ce serait à
ce serait fou de faire ça aujourd'hui un
bon règlement divulgue pas les sortir
pardon les règlements ne veut pas sortir
des états unis je pense que la plus 2 on
en voit c'est que la plupart des états
même les pays en développement moins
avancé tiennent au système de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce
parce que non seulement 1 il ya une
fonction de négociation qui les
intéresse énormément c'est de l'aide au
développement
c'est un forum de discussion
exceptionnelle pour eux ils bénéficient
de subsides à la formation etc et les
étapes plutôt que d'être en dehors et de
subir un bilatéralisme finalement de se
faire tordre le bras par des états qui
sont plus
sans clé l'heure les petits états dit on
est plus fort quand on est unis et qu'on
peut négocier à plusieurs au sein de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce
donc même les pays les moins avancés
tiennent à l'organisation donc
finalement il ya une sorte de confiance
en l'organisation est le seul qui fait
pas vraiment confiance finalement c'est
laisser le leader historique
il va falloir y aller vous aviez encore
dans ce dont je voulais faire le
parallèle avec l'accord des états unis
et mexique canada qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous qui êtes négociateurs de
l'om c est ce que c'est un bon accord
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
l'accord qui vient d'être signé
aujourd'hui pour qui voilà l'accord de
l'accord états unis mexicano lundi
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
qu'est ce que j'en pense que ça
ressemble énormément à l'alena
donc c'est c'est un peu la photographie
la même là on a un accord de libre
échange qui est assez similaire il ya
des avancées très très intéressante en
matière de droits humains et en matière
d'environnement c'est l'accord le plus
progressiste qui est aujourd'hui sur la
plate et sa liste vraiment il ya un
mécanisme judiciaire qui permet de
maintenir les dons qui permet de
protéger les droits humains en matière
commerciale au judiciaire is le respect
de l'environnement ce qui n'était pas le
cas jusqu'à présent donc c'est énorme
c'est vraiment des grosses grosses
avancées il ya certains secteurs qui en
paye le prix
on peut penser aux producteurs laitiers
au canada qui sont un peu ceux qui en
payent le passé ça tient à coups de ce
côté là et à des choses assez
épouvantable qui leur sont faites
on a réussi à maintenir l'exception
culturelle même s'il ya une serre donc
c'est quand même aussi à caen mais aussi
des gains là-dessus la culture a pris le
secoue ou hop en a perdu l'image tout va
bien le pilote de dick tout va bien
[Rires]
pour les principaux désaccords que stop
ça ressemble énormément à ce qu'on avait
auparavant monsieur professeur pavot
merci infiniment d'avoir accepté le
multi je sens qu'on va le revoir un jour
bientôt et chargé de cours à la faculté
de droit des institutions est un
spécialiste de la question de l' omc d
accord et je vous remercie infiniment
d'avoir ouvert cette porte sur les
inégalités et puis au fil de la
conversation on découvrait que les
choses pouvaient peut-être être remodelé
dans le sens où tous les êtres humains
aimerait que ça se passe parce qu'on
n'est pas des corporations on est des
êtres humains avant tout on aimerait que
le commerce ça se passe de façon morale
humaine dépend de tous de tous donc de
le faire et de façon égalitaire et plus
possible bon écoute on a besoin de jouer
un peu là les cours universités c'est
tellement fatigué écoutez donc vous avez
tous perdu 20 points sauf paloma donc la
ccin soit elle a créé la règle la chine
est tout seul là où on peut perdre
combien de points qu'elle charge la
question
le mcc rangée contre le canada est
derrière les pays européens qui
soutenaient que la chasse aux phoques
étaient cruelles et non nécessaire oui
ça commence avec brigitte sy ça va sans
doute se terminer un jour avec belge et
à écouter sinon l'histoire
je vous demande pas en quelle année ça
commence et 1980 184 je vous ai pas que
ça je demande en quelle année
est ce que l'om s'est rangé derrière le
l'union européenne qui avait décidé
d'interdire des produits de la chasse du
phoque sur edwards vous est ce que ca en
est ce que ces bébés en 2010 est ce que
c'est c'est en 2017 ou encore j'adore
toujours ça est-ce que céder aucune de
ces réponses
j'aime ça je mettrai 2017 2017 ce serait
très sain qu'on a envie des phoques
passé dans le
attention aux robots la cua par elie
2014 2015 quelque chose comme ça mais
attendez j'ai pas je sais pas défini
2017 2014 2015 il faudrait arrêter une
année là parce qu'on est inquiet oui oui
allant du port 2007-2009 est clair
aucune de ces réponses parce que je dis
que ces deux mises à cadencer pas dans
le choix de dépenses semble trop récente
mai 2010 semble trop loin de tincques
mai 2010
mais ça fait longtemps qu'on voit pas
les phoques 2007 à 2010 moi c'est le rio
mais il n'a pas répondu
aucune sa réponse et qui a répondu
aucune de ces réponses soit les deux
vous conservez vos points 2 vous perdez
30 points 50 50 66 81 81 très bien oui
mais vous remontez vos remontées
on n'avait pas perdu vos points et n'a
pas eu besoin un sévère 4 vous avez
raison c'est quelque chose que tu l'a
d'abord finalement c'est en 2013
pour répondre à toutes celles et ceux
qu'ils ont évoqué l'organisation
mondiale du commerce
ils ont dit oui l'union européenne n'a
pas droit
techniquement d'interdire sur son
territoire c'est c'est pas approprié ses
comptes les règles du commerce
mais pour des raisons éthiques
concernant le bien-être des animaux
l'interdiction est justifié donc pour
des raisons éthiques concernant les
animaux a justifié c'est nouveau c'est
nouveau paradigme démocratique
c'est vrai qu'on commence apprend à
prendre en considération ce type de
choses
c'est l'époque où c'est quel point c'est
important pour elle ces questions de
commerce humanitaire elle a fait une
entrevue au tour et seulement ont valu
dans dans les dossiers de radio canada
international et voir ce que ça donne
sur le web cette semaine et on va voir
que regarder la carte du monde sait
marquer quoi vous lisez paloma vous nous
aider oui le programme commercial
progressistes du canada l'alena et au
delà cliquant là dessus pour voir à quel
moment ça a été écrit parce que je m'en
souviens pas honnêtement j'ai pas
répondre tu as toujours aux questions je
pose et c'est assez récent salle louis
joseph est une vidéo là dessus sur skype
cette année j'avais fait une entrevue à
quelqu'un du cedeao n'est ce pas on va
descendre au tessin c'est sur le site
web toutes les informations se trouvent
sur le site web s'est il pas se tromper
voilà j'avais préparé une vidéo avec un
extrait de lui qui parlait mais bon le
temps pour autant fait en fait là sa
démission
il faut c'est un très bel entrevue très
intéressant son point de vue le point de
vue du side out et un canadien
donc un centre de réflexion économique
économie jamais trop loin
l'iris centre droit ok c'est quoi ces
anglais donc il expliqué ces canadiens
pas anglais oui mais ce canadien anglais
d'avoir cette conversation avec lui
parce qu'il m'a expliqué de points de
vue qui font partie aussi des valeurs
canadien depuis lé canada défend à
travers les différents forums
économiques
voilà des réflexions à travers le monde
donc c'était à écouter mais on n'a pas
le temps de présenter cette émission
nous ton est très précieux mais wipro
précieux trop de questions autour de la
table n'est ce pas écoutez je voulais
vous amener à 7 c'est tout nouveau
sourire si on va rester sur les rssi on
a fait du montage visuel c'est nouvelles
applications disponibles vous allez nous
expliquer est ce que quelqu'un ici
autour de la table de dire de quoi il
s'agit j'ai une application de ces déjà
sur les tablettes moi et sur mon
téléphone aussi donc vous aussi pas le
bon en fait c'est l'application
c'est ça avant on rentrait à travers ce
quinquennat qui peut nous montrer à quoi
ça ressemble jamais dans notre version
alors c'est qu'on a fait c'est l'équipe
de rci en chine en tête
il ya développé l'application air c'est
à dire que vous pouvez rentrer dans les
places toro ios
apple store pour aller chercher
l'application ça ça fait du bien du côté
il faut pas être connectés dans les
sites web vous pouvez directement avoir
un accès direct et d'une application
puis l'application c'est vraiment
beaucoup plus bien en plus c'est une
petite vidéo en prime ça qu'on va aller
on fait comme si on est sûr ce google et
chercher l'application
alors c'est en temps réel téléphone
oui ça s'est fait à l'ordinateur gros
ordinateurs professionnels met sur la
table est aussi vous pouvez faire la
même chose donc on va google et on fera
du canada international et on va voir
apparaître en 5 langues différentes
évidemment vous sélectionnez pas
espagnol c'était contre un avec c'est
une chose qu'un discuté aujourd'hui avec
marie-claude moi par exemple je vais mon
téléphone à l'anglais moi je vais
l'application en français puis en
espagnol alors je quand je rentre mais à
travers les flotteurs vers le site de
lci il va tomber toujours hinglé passe
mon système opératif est en anglais mais
avec l'application on peut choisir
vraiment très bien d'une langue à
l'autre on a un choix de langues
si vous faites l'espagnol vous avez
l'anglais français si vous avez
l'anglais c'est les français puis
l'espagnol si vous savez les chinois
c'est l'anglais et le français
mais on peut cliquer à côté de ça c'est
très bien pour les gens qui habitent ici
au canada par exemple qui parlait plus
de la ddt qui veulent fort à toi oui qui
veulent aller fait fuyez dans d'autres
langues pour voir qu'est ce qu'on fait à
radio canada international alors c'est
très bien fait
puis on vous invite à les télécharger
puis il faut dire que quand on travaille
en français on ne trouve pas décemment
les mêmes contenus en anglais
donc c'est important de pouvoir les voir
comment comment on travaille toutes les
équipes d essayer donc que c'est beau en
fait c'est très beau l'application est
vraiment belle et pratique
jallet va falloir tous très dur ça en
espagnol pour l'émission en espagnol
d'accord cette émission commence dans à
peu près quoi lui minutes non non non
mais dites vous avez temps d'antenne ou
l'attribution elles sont le point de jeu
le frère une question oui c'est un 5 1
points j'ai aussi une image de la
semaine
j'ai beaucoup de choses à quelle heure
je peux terminer sans casser les misys
alors écoutez vous avez tant temps
supplémentaire à bordeaux sans avoir
écouté je suis l'image de la semaine
je réponds seulement par oui ou par non
pas récente et l'apport les m je savais
que vous feriez pas ça mais moi j'ai
deux semaines
à chaque fois qu'on d'ivoire ont
représenté d'image la semaine tout le
monde se tourne vers ses partisans pour
la voir c'est l'image
à chaque âge que c'est celle là qui va
présenter l'émission mais cette fois
j'ai déjà oui ok alors l'image en at
elle imagé dans ma tête
quelle est cette image je réponds pas je
réponds bah oui pardon vous poser des
questions je dirais ça c'est une femme
le portrait d'une femme ça pourrait être
portrait d'une femme le faber oui
tatouages et des jeunes stylistes
attendait que vont faire les autres pour
dévier parce que vous savez tout non
mais ça c'est vraiment un enfant ça
pourrait être un enfant aussi oui tout à
fait oui la réponse est oui à ce qu'elle
a pu la question et papouilles
par son arrêt canadien c'est des
canadiens c'est là le regarde et on a
des images aussi l'image la semaine
c'est valérie d'allaiter aurait été
réparé dans les régions du québec et la
petite
et puis elle est morte dans who you
qu'on faisait depuis 2005
très expérimenté et habitué à la vie
d'un hors la vie en forêt avec son
coéquipier son amant son ami qui est
d'origine norvégienne et trappeurs
professionnels
c'est pas des touristes comme vous c'est
ça il vivait là bas depuis trois mois je
pense qu'ils étaient elles étaient en
congé de maternité son enfant de 10 ans
10 mois et voilà et puis ils ont été
surpris comme ça lors d'une marche à
l'extérieur leur cabane pendant que
l'époux était houleux conjointe et à
l'extérieur afin de vérifier si trappe
je me suis posé la question le disque si
oui pourquoi il y aurait fait ça s'est
senti attaqué l'un près ça il faut faire
une autopsie
[Musique]
il ya un caractère agressif ministres
qui disent sagesse blanc qui sont
provoquées par la proximité juste à
proximité peut provoquer c'est ça les a
surpris donc pour lui c'est d'ailleurs
il évite les humains mais ben qu'il faut
faire du bruit puisse à angers en
principe ça aide ça normalement les
éloigner puis en disant 10 mai mais
c'est quand même l'hiver qui approche
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils n'étaient pas en
hibernation bandits temps est plus doux
alors peut-être qu'il était sorti encore
une fois c'est pas normal pour un ours
d'attendre puis de continuer à essayer
de trouver un petit peu de nourriture
c'est une triste histoire c'est la
francophonie la bande en ue conquis
étaient saisis soit 1500 citoyens
francophones seulement dans une région
extrêmement éloignée j'ai déjà été à
whitehorse puis j'ai rencontré les gens
de la de l'association franco yukonnaise
c'est vraiment ils sont très actifs ils
sont très unis aussi sont comme une
grande famille donc c'est ce qui est une
grande perte pour eux soit qui a fait
tous les journaux les médias cette
semaine
et puis c'est pas fini ça continue 1
parce que on veut savoir ce qui s'est
passé plus bonne question à vous poser
qu'est ce que s'est passé
on est prêt pour le change de temps
voilà on y va voir dernier jeu combien
de points à perdre sur un an alors on
rappelle les scores oui 66 50 81 81 tous
les 2 80 donc cdc laisser des champions
pour le moment
comme pour 50 points à perdre
est ce qu'on peut
est-ce qu'on peut s'abstenir quitté
quand vous mais si je quittais ce que
j'ai gardées règles du jeu de l'om s'est
alors voici la question où le prétend
que le prix argus pas le prénom pull
mais ça serait beau com - préambule
prénuptial le canada est membre de l'
omc depuis le 1er janvier 2015 1995 je
me répète mais je veux être sûr qu'on
comprenne le canada était impliqué dans
beaucoup de dossiers de plaintes sur
laquelle le mcr dû statuer ou je te tue
encore dans quel type de cause à deux
cellules étaient impliqués le plus
souvent choix de réponse à en tant que
plaignant b en tant que défendeurs haut
lignon entrants qui se plaît au rythme
pays qui se plaît oui les états unis
bois d'oeuvre des choses comme ça
résonne en tout cas alors le gérer
plaignants au seigneur et mon dieu
les canaris sont tellement poli passé ou
qui ont le temps de se plaindre bah
écoute ci sont souvent contredits de
défense d'une attaque accusé qui se
défend l'idée n'est pas de défense au
hockey et au milieu on attaque alors la
bonne dépense c'est à en tant que
plaignant
on reprend dans 50 fois la victime alors
moi j'aimerais savoir qui a gagné 4 1
on a dit klaus vous avez toujours 80
puis vous êtes-vous à 30 30 points mais
vous aurais dit m aucune ne se répondent
en fait il existe aucune de ces réponses
y aurait pu exister c'est qui est donc
de 4 oui on est observateur on a été
mentionné par un autre pays on a une ou
un pli que par la force des choses
francis 165 heures comme ça où on dit
par exemple benakis plainte contre les
états unis
même situation qu'à ses professeurs
bavaud qui les défendra exactement voilà
j'ai perdu
vous avez tout perdu mon nom me reste 20
55 ans points 81 81 30 points soit +
perdante de tout le père d'un nom des
gagnants applaudissons la fantastique
fantastic 1 il faut le faire quand on
perd pas ses points alors merci beaucoup
paloma monsieur samir ben merci steve je
fais un cadeau vraiment gentil et puis
les eaux gimeno la semaine prochaine à
c'est un peu chaque fois la semaine
prochaine et m'a dit claude